in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Mitch
and Becky are with us hey guys how are
you good anything
welcome welcome good to have you guys so
where you from just outside of Wisconsin
oh very cool welcome to Nashville thank
you thank you to have you in here all
the way here to do your debt-free
screaming yes yeah how fun very fun how
much have you paid off
we paid off seventy seventy five
thousand dollars
seventy five thousand bucks and how long
did that take nineteen months why did it
go and your range of income during that
time we went between sixty-five thousand
and now at about 110 good for you
and what do you guys do for a living I
run the exercise program and an assisted
living independent living facility mm-hm
and then I'm a village administrator so
a city manager for a small community in
Northeast Wisconsin very cool good for
you good for you so what kind of debt
was the 7500 we had 60,000 student loans
just like about three-quarters of our
generation maybe seven eight and then
fifteen thousand of that was IVF so in
vitro fertilization treatment okay
alright Wow so did you have some money
saved that you throughout this or you
just cash flow through all this we had I
think we threw about four or five
thousand dollars at the beginning from
savings into it and then we cash flowed
the rest you just been on beans and yeah
yeah a lot of rice and small pieces of
chicken
not necessarily beans oh my gosh wow I
mean you've been hardcore those numbers
are tight well yeah they are we did we
we gave up a lot of stuff throughout
just trips with friends and lots of
destination wedding stuff like that at
our age a lot of that's going on right
now we didn't get to do a lot of that
but found some other fun um for nineteen
whole months nineteen yeah yep how long
have you guys been married almost four
years summer so what happened nineteen
months ago tell me the story how you
this journey unfolds
well even even so two years ago we
received a book from Becky's uncle Chris
net Rita the old money makeover and that
kind of got everything started and go
our heads but even before that my mom
for the longest time had listened to you
so I knew of you mm-hmm
no offense it was a little weird for an
18 year old to hear debt-free yeah so
but when we got the book Becky started
reading it and then we came down here
for a visit and two years ago
essentially now we came into your studio
watched a live show oh wow and then for
nine hours on the way back I was told
and talked to about this great idea to
go deaf no arguing nice little chat for
910 hours whatever it was nine hours as
a person stuck in a car I like a ear by
ear March the pages I wanted him to read
because I knew he wouldn't read the
whole thing right away and I said I
don't want to see you skimming here's
the ones I want you to read the first
three baby steps are something that but
then we we switch jobs in July of that
year and then August we made the
decision I bought in and I started
buying into everything and we we made
the decision to go okay what was it made
you decide to buy in
I had never because of my job I deal
with finances all the time but there
always a city or village level so it's
big finances and I never took an
interest in ours I said you can handle
that I got the stuff at work finally I
said man $800 a month and payments and
student loans is just driving up the
wall
I mean we can't do anything even if we
wanted to take trips to Europe or other
places we can't afford it unless we had
a credit card and maybe two credit cards
mm-hmm so I think at that point I was
like all right not only do I have to
take an interest in what we do
financially between the two of us but
we've got to get ourselves out of the
situation so when he decides he's going
to stick his nose in this Becky and he
says okay I'm in how did that feel to
you felt awesome it was a lot of talking
back and forth about it and he would
just say okay
so it felt really great you feel really
supported as a wife especially as a
young couple when we have all of our
friends that are not necessarily doing
some of these concepts and our new
lifestyle now so it felt awesome to be
supported if we're sitting with friends
and somebody says something he's like
you know we're doing this and it's not
me saying it all the time that was the
biggest thing for me yeah there's a
there's a sense of a sense of unity a
sense of appreciation that goes with
that that's very cool so what do you
tell people the secret to get
that is now that you've done it for me
it's blocking out the noise there are a
lot of people out there in your life
that have different ideas about how you
should do something I mean whether it's
hey credit cards are okay if you pay
them off or why don't you own a house
yet or you know let's go on this
vacation you're young have fun for me
it's you know who you are just do that
you know be who you are do what you can
to make your life better and help others
in the meantime but don't do what other
people tell you to do yeah mm-hmm I
think for me it was being happy with
what we have I mean what's wrong with
her in those that pair of shoes to a
wedding why do I need to go get some
else does anybody even care what I'm
wearing anyway no does anybody even care
what we're doing what our house
decorations look like the fact that we
rent a house that we don't own No so
realizing a lot of that was a big key
for us yeah you're the only ones that
really care exactly on to it and yeah
that there's a tremendous power and
being released from what other people
think yep and I guess another hard part
for this is I was diagnosed with breast
cancer during this whole process too so
we just recently got done with
treatments for that so I went through
the surgery we that's for the inferred
IVF in vitro fertilization came from
when you go through chemo you might not
have a chance of having kids yet and we
hadn't so we throw some embryos just
dealing with that process the whole time
was and still doing no we didn't slow
down we didn't have to we paused when we
found out just like you say we had just
kept throwing stuff in our bank account
and when we felt like it was okay to
start again because we had it under
control we kept going so that was a big
deal for us so how you doing doing great
yeah just finished chemo maybe a month
ago and very small tumor but just
because I was 27 at the time they throw
the kitchen sink yeah yeah so yeah we
got through it great and lots of support
and then this journey too it was a
really big we wanted to accomplish that
while we're going through cancer that
was a big I kept working that extra
money kept going through our debt to so
it's a big motivator true so yeah that's
amazing
mm-hmm thus the sock at exactly yeah
exactly your style and that's all I'm
yeah yeah
that's all I'm saying yeah you're living
and you're stylin yeah
proud of me very cool good for you yeah
you kick cancers but that's but both in
a couple of years you pretty well took
down everybody
yeah yes I'm getting scared of nothing
now yeah exactly yeah yes brings two
people together you wouldn't believe so
I guess so yeah no congratulations we're
proud for you guys thank you thank
colorful we got a copy of Chris Hogan's
book retire inspired for you that's the
next chapter in your story be
millionaires yes and we want to hear
back from you when your millionaires
maybe in the meantime feel free to call
in anytime that's what we're here for so
rowdy you guys did you bring some people
with you just you guys our parents and
sister and me up cousin and it's yeah a
lot of people a lot of lot of good
support a lot of good cheerleaders and
we had a kind of that so that's very
cool very cool good to have the posse
here to support Lee that's awesome
all right Mitch and Becky Oshkosh
Wisconsin $75,000 a top man in 19 months
oh and by the way we're going to be
cancer while we're at it
65,000 a110 income counting down let's
air a debt free scream three two one
we're death
[Music]
oh goodness Wow
unbelievable that's fabulous absolutely
well done you know it it's a given that
you're going to have life happened to
you while you handle money it's a given
what's not a given is how you respond to
it and that just brings tears to my eyes
the courage that couple I mean that they
can get just a little inconvenienced I
mean she goes to chemo and they still do
this that's incredible courage and you
know you just you have to decide what
you're going to do and you have to go do
it regardless of what people think and
regardless of what circumstances are
thrown at you you go win anyway Wow
inspiring stuff this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]